we've talked about this vicious circle
of the need to legalize cannabis in
order to end much of what's going on
with the war on drugs some politicians
say well in order to legalize it we need
more research on it but the research
itself is difficult to do because of the
current legal status of cannabis so it
creates this impossible circle that I
think we generally understand we've got
some really good news about this which
is that Jefferson University announced
that it has received a 3 million dollar
donation from two Australian
philanthropists Barry and joy Lambert to
fund medical research into cannabis and
they're actually going to be renaming
the cannabis research center the Lambert
Center for the Study of medicinal
cannabis and hemp now there's some
disagreement over the the reality of
this Jefferson University says it's the
quote first major health sciences
university in the US to establish a
medical cannabis research center however
Ole Miss has had a cannabis research
center for many years uh so it's unclear
whether this is considered the first
major or the first miner or whatever the
case is but this is still really really
big news and you know when I was at
UMass Rachel I thought we had a cannabis
research center it turns out it was just
a frat house I was convinced that we had
a major cannabis research out there uh
okay so it in all seriousness now though
uh we've gotta break the cycle right i
mean the scheduling of cannabis as a
schedule 1 drug at the at the national
level the DEA getting the opportunity to
change that saying that they are not
going to uh we we need to be researching
this in a more serious way and my
concern is jeff Sessions incoming
attorney general it's not exactly going
to be the most welcoming environment for
marijuana research is it yeah and
schedule one means that it's the most
dangerous possible drug there's no
medical uses for it whatsoever and it's
on the same same platform as things like
heroin meth and LSD reservations I
wonder if there's going to be a shift
now from Israel which is kind of our
unofficial offshore area for cannabis
research yeah exactly i wonder if this
is going to set actually a positive
precedent to kind of shift research over
here because as we know
to get anything done through the FDA it
takes about a lifetime yeah and that
there's there's a broader question
around the world which is what's wrong
in the united states that it's taking so
long to really start doing serious
subsidized research on the benefits of
both cannabis and hemp and when you
think about pharmaceutical lobbyists
tobacco lobbyist alcohol lobbyists the
fact that count the count was government
agencies and police departments around
the country depend on up prosecuting and
and going after cannabis in marijuana in
the way that we do to fund themselves
you've got the prison industrial complex
which makes a ton of money from the
status quo of marijuana if you follow
the money Pat you usually figure out
what's going on in not only in the
United States but definitely in the
United States yeah there's a lot of
people in the pharmaceutical companies
that would be poised to lose a lot of
money if marijuana gain more traction in
terms of medical uses last best last
thing on this Rachel there's sometimes
the thought from the anti legalization
community that we don't have any actual
medical evidence about medical uses for
marijuana that could not be further from
the truth there are over 100 different
studies that at the small level have
shown at minimum potential for medical
marijuana used to treat a variety of
conditions and symptoms if not actual
success in doing so that's true but I
really think the big underlying issue
here is how the FDA is classifying it
because if you think about all the
research with the microbiome in
classifying stool as a drug because who
profits from stool yes that's a it's not
a very profitable business I know Pat's
looked into businesses involving stool
and he ended up producing the David
Pakman shows I think that tells you how
much how much potential Pat's on that
business I decided not to invest it is I
have to invest i'm on twitter at the
pakman you can also reach us on twitter
at david pakman show will be back after
this warby parker is offering a free
five day home try-on to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses i
personally wear warby parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker try
l.com / TDPS I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing